es un patrón de la leche
esa es la reflexión
sería un trabajo increíble o la
profesión que me encanta un bache móvil
establecido
[Música]
al menos
o
[Música]
no es entonces
aunque repito algo desde el mochica
apretar porque estás porque me enseñaron
que visualizaron
algunas de esas pruebas se fueron
modificando con el paso del tiempo otras
desaparecieron pero hubo algunas que se
mantuvieron firmes desde el principio
bien hay que analizar y evaluar el
alcance de esos lodos y descubrí
efectivamente hablando de la historia
y definitivamente no
porque la verdad si se lleva a las
oportunidades si no lo es
vivimos en un mundo lleno de patrones
desde que nacemos ya tenemos una serie
de órganos
[Música]
te permite sentir cierto confort
cuando no estás
alguna vez un verso no es la me dijo que
no toda la vida enseña que cuando nos
esforzamos tanto por convertir en regla
a aquellos menores estamos abandonando
la valiosa estupendísimos
e incluso para ellos
yo siempre había soñado con tener una
era
y para poder
[Música]
y me pasa en realidad simples
si conocieran
sí
en una decisión que los comisarios
y el ser
y es que hay historias
suplica dar un paso
llegan dos minutos
y de paso estar explicando a la gente
que te rodea
y sentirse observados
hay ruidos que no se miden únicamente
[Música]
entonces
y si no llegaba
porque no es que no esté la cuestión es
que no sabemos qué va a pasar en un
futuro y quizás esas oportunidades
tengan otro tiempo otro espacio incluso
otra forma y yo tomé la que sin duda ha
sido la decisión más fuerte nuevamente
en una vez y al mismo tiempo
el acto deshonesto primero para mi vida
e
pero
quiero sentarme y practicar
utilizo
en todas
solo
es un objetivo
o sea no
estas son siempre ver lo poco que es la
decisión de casa
del entorno
[Música]
como tiene
no digas
sólo bueno y mejor está presente
10 y pasta
es como si tuvieras que vivir pequeños
duelos mientras estás construyendo un
sonido
en términos económicos cuando tomas una
decisión
[Música]
hoy yo creo que todos esos amigos que
dices en el camino son pisadas o las que
necesitas
por esto
y empecé mi preparación física para un
tratamiento agresivo en el cuerpo y
hormonalmente de esas 2
y emocional yo no podía perder de vista
cuál fue el porcentaje de los
procedimientos
en las luchas más fuertes
[Música]
i
puedes volver el doctor en este momento
me ayudó a crecer como persona la
primera
nuevos
allí aprendí el valor de la paciencia
las cosas no surgen de los sueños y
tienen tiempo bueno formal se inicia de
algo para que los seres humanos no
decidimos es justamente
pasa 25 días
y hombros
y
[Música]
y se está viviendo
tiene
y
y la transferencia
voy convirtiendo en persona muy
disciplinada
y sin importar todo mi esfuerzo para
vinificación después de 10 días recibir
mi terrible y negativo
es de verdad
el 40
tú puedes actuar como quieras las cosas
[Música]
en estos términos
incluso objetivos
a veces pienso que sí
es en tanto una persona
el trabajo puede ser en sus misiones
y muchas
y aunque pareciera ser el mismo una
serie de complicaciones de la tuvieron y
rafa durante hora y media de segunda
acción y en ese tiempo en el que estuve
luchando contra mina vez a punto de
vencer estamos listos y sobre saber
y los siguientes días de trabajo
y por lo menos me di cuenta
es el 2100 208
defensivas o simples
y entonces entendí
me gusta
la vida a veces no es sólo que estabais
siendo temas en su modo y si es un
poquito listo
sabes a buscar el segundo eso está
haciendo falta internacional en el
equipo
si quieres saber el siguiente pleno de
su vida entonces sobre es una pausa
dentro si lo que ves es viajar dentro de
mis dos opciones
bueno es mientras la vida
con formas de acostumbrar
y bueno
y nada más
no
o
las aves y sabes a buscar
dirigir
sin miedo
perder el equilibrio es el menudo una
forma de llegar
yo tomé una decisión y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]